I loved when the new generation of
comics came in which was Bobby and Rena
ZZ and did Ari ever go anywhere yeah
he's big now other than the ghosts he's
killing it oh yeah yeah I saw him in New
York
to me it was like taxi drunk
he's a snapperhead yeah you know like I
said you know Bobby Sebastian all these
guys were the new guys and there was so
much more fun than the guys that came up
with because number one I always stood
away from the pack it's just the way it
went because when my career took off
like what comics go through today with
the politically correct stuff III piss
on them now because when my career took
off I had the world it was like picture
if you are the only one ever being
attacked for political correctness
that's what I became the biggest comic
in the world hands down and everybody
knows that to this day like I love when
I talk to the guys that are honest about
the [ __ ] like like you know who talks
about it the best Joe Rogan like he goes
yeah there were guys today do it like if
he has a comic like Ari you know that
jealous prick but if you remember in in
the and I love Ari I'm fine oh I love
him he's a good-looking guy in OGG lis
one of the worst no nice guy I'm friends
with but even when I filmed what we
called the show yeah you know with my
camera
he was the antagonist that was his part
so whoever was my friend in the show Ari
would come over to them this is on film
he goes what are you talking about
like he's done like he you want to talk
to me I'm the big star now yeah you know
so he was the antagonist like Steve
Rannazzisi not Steve Rannazzisi way
simone steve simone and mouth he played
the part i call
misery you know how he's always
miserable that stuff and angry you know
yes lightened up over the years no but
no I'm friends with it I know yeah what
I'm saying is his part aren't on film
was always upset and angry you see him
come through the double doors at a
comedy you know of the kitchen going
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] just angry yeah
you know Mike Moran oh yeah you know who
that is
I know who Mike Marino is yeah yeah okay
so no because he never became like a big
star you know why is that why do you
think that happened let me can I ask you
that why do you think some people just
don't make it they don't have the
x-factor
yeah the the that's that star thing Wow
you know I use nothing he doesn't I know
but I born with that or can you learn
now you're born with that right you
either got better you know Wow and um
that's why they do a show now called the
x value either have that you know right
you know you know they're people that
stand on stage could just not be funny
but they become superstars because they
have a star they were star rah that's
what Mitzi used to look for you know and
um but anyway Mike Marino is a marina on
Murano because I had two different
friends once Maria knowing I used to
call him Mike Marino all right well
whatever it is yeah you know yeah we his
part was called he was the Russian even
though he was Italian why did you pause
I guess I don't know I don't I don't do
that again let's talk it was crazy that
you did that
okay all right so anyway his part was
the Russian yes because he's he's
Italian but he's a blond Italian yeah
you know I'm very light-skinned yes guy
like I don't even think people believe
he's Italian because of her
so his part was the Russian Rhino
Sebastian was always puzzled
yeah Honda in the tape yeah like he
would watch me like from a distance and
go with what's going on yeah you know
and why is he walking an Ari would be
like he's got the carries just looking
for something to do you understand yeah
like one time my son Dylan just buried
Ari on film Wow I'm Dylan was seven okay
yeah if you saw this clip yeah you'd be
amazed because Ari's playing foosball
with Dylan yeah you know so Ari's at
that time what 30 Dylan 7 yeah
and for whatever reason our he's going
you know I don't really think your dad's
funny you know
yeah and Dylan just looks at him you
know and don't goes what you say you
know because III don't think your dad is
funny yeah like he's needling the kid
and doing goes did you ever do the
Rosemont and Chicago and then he goes
did you ever do three nights at the
mecca in Milwaukee which is actually
where Bill burr saw me and decided I'm
gonna do that Wow yeah like I love here
in these guys story yes I become friends
with them you know how could I just say
something about Dylan and Max no but
wait let me just say this but can I be
on to this scene is to a seven-year-old
yeah yeah it's going like he's broken
and he goes well you know I work
[Music]
seven-year-old opposed accredit right
you know are you gonna can we see it or
know how do we see these tapes well
there is gonna be a documentary nice you
know and I'm working on all that now
please good because I think that's gotta
come out that's in some form it's the
funniest [ __ ] I can't wait what I was
telling you would [ __ ] Armstrong yeah
is so we're shooting the same where
we're gonna go dump garbage which wanted
a few things they took from my life
right that they're gonna use in one
the episodes other than what they made
up instead of just like my son say if
you did a show with Axl Rose when you
let him be Axl yeah why don't you just
listen to my father's stories and let
him be dice yeah okay but don't you have
the power to go up let's do this now
when you're working with a network you
know how about that because then you
become the problem right all right so
we're shooting a scene with another
director we're all right so we get in
the truck doors close cut reset open the
two back doors slam those open the
moonroof slam that yeah oh no I had him
shoot through the moon roof to get
angles of the doors so in editing it
could be like the doors closed a hundred
times like they're coming out to the car
shut the gate g-g-g-gia
and then the car goes yeah so but what
Scott would do in editing in editing
yeah just cut out all the funny you're
not because it wasn't his idea and when
he came over to the director going what
are you doing I go is he directing are
you direct Rock he shouldn't have even
been on the set when there was another
direct yeah yeah you're right you know
like let us do our thing
let dice be dice but as a producer he
could still go to the editing room and
[ __ ] cut it out and that's what he
would do yeah you know yeah but you know
what's funny is anytime I've done my own
show yeah you know it's always an honor
to work with me they give you that
[ __ ] oh it's such an honor you're a
legend you're an icon till you're on the
set wrong you know